ich hätte gerne eine haarverlängerung
detlef müller muss vor die kamera die
spd braucht sein gesicht für die
wahlplakate denn müller will wieder in
den bundestag
wahlkampf in corona zeigen die
abgekämpft heid aus dem gesicht
geschminkt
[Musik]
so mache jetzt ganz wieder fotos ganz
viele um die 100 200 stecken damit
aussortiert dann verdichtet sich das so
wurden denen schon abzeichnen muss und
das ist dann das motiv
sechs
bundestagsabgeordnete beobachten wir
seit jahren auch jetzt im wahlkampf
alle haben eine eigene geschichte die
auswahl eher zufällig nach einem merkmal
warum familiennamen
[Musik]
wo ist mein ganzes grümpel hinlegen
doch westernhagen oder rammstein
[Musik]
politiker und
investoren
auch schön
weil ich viel sport
detlef müller ist gelernter lokführer
2005 wird er mdb mitglied des deutschen
bundestages und nimmt sich eines ganz
fest vor mein prinzip ist eigentlich die
glaubwürdigkeit die bodenhaftung dass
ich noch weiß was der bürger vor ort
welche probleme hat und darum geht's die
probleme die die leute vor ort haben
hier noch berlin zu tragen weil viele
das hier ganz auf den berlin auch nicht
mehr ganz so sagen gut wissen wie es den
leuten vorgeht
witze über stützt zuviel spitzbübisch
freundlich erst mal
trauen
sie sich von nach wahlkampf
also ich glaube
weder die die leute draußen habe ich
jetzt mal noch wir haben überhaupt da
zeit lässt und auch keine zeit für
wahlkampf also wir fangen dadurch an mir
planen muss jetzt viel plant das
shooting guard damit erzeugen auch das
wahlkampf team arbeitet schon man
überlegt sich die geschichten wie man
den wahlkampf organisiert welcher welche
strategie dahinter liegt aber im
gegensatz zu vorhergehenden wahlkämpfen
ist dass diesmal auch alles ziemlich
weit weg
[Musik]
mitte märz auf der schwäbischen alb
beate müller gemmeke sitzt seit 2009 im
bundestag
für die grünen
die landtagswahl in baden württemberg
steht bevor sie unterstützt eine partei
freunden
falls sie noch fragen haben klar kann
man auch in videokonferenzen reden aber
dies ist wirklich in die augen gucken
und uns fühlen ja das ist natürlich ganz
anders wenn man wirklich hiergegen mit
den menschen tatsächlich redet und das
fehlt auch wirklich da habe ich ihnen
noch was zur wahl mit geben
zur landtagswahl ist nächste woche am
sonntag schon
die dritte corona welle rollt müller
gemmeke spürt den unmut der wähler
[Musik]
warum kann man nicht
aber sie wissen schon dass diese popelt
es ist jetzt erst da sind oder ich war
gerade beim test beim schnelltest also
mansfelder land hat ist alles recht
haben selbst keine lösungen aufzeigen
doch
die könne noch nicht da sein weil es
nicht genügend es gibt
momente aggressiv frauen sie nicht mit
mir reden im moment das mache ich nicht
ich finde es immer ambivalent zum einen
denke ich mir mein gott jetzt ist ein
jahr lang corona und eigentlich tragen
einige weisen gutes so dass eine eher
auf der anderen seite merke ich
natürlich dass die leute sehr wohl
genervt sind
dass sie dass sie verrückt werden dass
sie verunsichert sind natürlich und dass
sie einfach sagen jetzt muss aber mal
schluss sein und dann zum beispiel eben
wenn dann mütter eben sagen hier die wir
verlieren unsere kinder grad und
verbraucht setzt endlich strategien auch
in den schulen das kann ich alles
nachvollziehen und das merkt man
natürlich dass die menschen schon
langsam am limit einfach sind
am nachmittag im benachbarten reutlingen
auf dem marktplatz werden alle parteien
für sich einen tag zuvor wurde ein afd
stand attackiert die folge wahlkampf mit
starker polizeipräsenz
die angst der krise füttert die extreme
politiker müssen sich schützen vor hass
und vor anfeindungen mehr denn je
wahrscheinlich etwas und
gedenken wurde gehen gehört und
ihr feier doch party ist jetzt in die
hinterzimmer und die
regierungsentscheidung ihre
sind 1000 knaller wie der methodischen
blut oder wissen sie was mit solchen
aussagen
disqualifiziert sich selbst zu 100
prozent sie wissen was ich denke wir
können sie nicht wissen wie gewohnt
stattfinden
dann lassen sie es doch dann kann es ja
weitergehen wie fühlt sich das an
reibung zu machen und
sehen nein das ist natürlich nicht
normal das gab es früher nicht da war es
sozusagen die auseinandersetzung
inhaltlicher art aber das sind sozusagen
die veränderungen die durch die afg
einfach entstanden sind
fünf monate vor der bundestagswahl in
franken
aufbauarbeit für einen abgeordneten der
asd
sie gucken so neugierig wir beißen nicht
trauen sie sich mit uns zu sprechen
weil wir von der ganz ganz bösen
rechtsextremen partei sind die kleinen
kinder frisst ihr blut trinkt sie wissen
doch alles was man sicher über uns
erzählen
[Musik]
hansjörg müller unternehmensberater seit
2017 im parlament er steht im
rechtsextremen flügel
angefeindet ohne ende weil wir uns
wirklich für die wiedereinführung eines
demokratischen systems stark machen dazu
muss man den rechtsstaat wieder
einführen wenn man noch selbst denkt und
sich kritisch hinterfragt was uns in der
öffentlichkeit anlügen vorgesetzt wird
dann ist man einen
verschwörungstheoretiker und wenn man
eben sagen wir mal zu sich selber und
seinen eigenen interessen steht und
keine selbstaufgabe betreibt dann ist
man ein nazi weil ich mein wenn unser
land weitere runde gewirtschaftet wird
es ist nur noch eine frage der zeit bis
wir im bürgerkrieg versinken und was
das in russland praktisch faschisten am
markt sind als er mich stört
grundsätzlich wenn menschenrechte mit
den füßen getreten werden ja und was ich
in dem ich also stört grundsätzlich wenn
menschenrechte missachtet werden wie
stört grundsätzlich wenn totalitäre
herrschaft systeme gegen die menschen
agieren ja so und das ist in deutschland
auch davon ein
nein ich spreche jetzt über deutschland
die bürgerlichen freiheiten sind heute
heute in russland wesentlich größer als
in deutschland weilte wird man nicht
gegängelt mit mit terror mit ihm klare
und mit masken terror das will ich ihnen
sagen ich kann als mensch ich möchte
dass politische weg haben ich kann als
mensch heutzutage in russland viel freie
leben als in deutschland chancen sich
doch an was hier los ist haben sich
russland nicht
wir sind hier
gegen die korona maßnahmen bietet müller
seit deren beginn das ding das macht
krank
auch im sommer 2020 auf einer
spontandemo in berlin
die kritik an den maßnahmen und deren
verhältnismäßigkeit wächst müller hofft
damals auf einen umsturz
ein rechter youtuber filmteam beide
suchen den krawall
[Musik]
ich habe ihn ganz klar ich habe ihn
nicht angegriffen ich stand im weg und
er hat mich schwer krempelt das hat
jeder gesehen
schon wieder geschoben ich finde es auch
von hinten noch angerempelt worden hast
du das gesehen ja
ja ich muss dazu sagen
da ich sage gar nichts mehr dazu ja wir
mit den leuten umgeht der protest kommt
damals von sehr unterschiedlichen seiten
müller hofft dass er die regierung
wegfliegt und den staat erschüttert
[Musik]
dass das hoffentlich hier wirklich
zeichnete kern eine bewegung wird
zurück in würzburg der afg
wahlkampfstand hat sich inzwischen
herumgesprochen in der linken szene
müllers helfer sind alarmiert
[Musik]
gerufen von den kollegen mit den haaren
also man sieht ja auch an der kleidung
wo die leute herziehen finde ich
hochinteressant
ich gehe jetzt mal zur polizei und
meldete dass
wir haben sie schon ziemlich nah an den
start gebracht wohl sagen würde
eigentlich fühlt müller sich unterdrückt
vom staat hier lässt es sich und seinen
stand von ihm beschützen
[Musik]
berlin der bundestag hat müller wohnt
hier in den sitzungswochen an diesem
morgen müssen die hemden zur reinigung
[Musik]
abgeordnete können in berlin einen
autofahrer dienst nutzen
macht müller aber heute nicht
zu reduzieren das gilt auch für die
fahrbereitschaft im zweitens finde ich
es gut auch mal nicht nur rumzusitzen
sondern sich zu bewegen und damit ich
auf die ausreichende schritte kommen
mache ich das auch
[Musik]
müller ist gelernter bankkaufmann und
seit vier jahren volksvertreter
mit 30 einer der jüngsten in der
unionsfraktion
krone setzt auch in grenzen
geschafft das geschlossen
und jetzt
hat jemand followers man muss ich dafür
nachmittag ab 14 uhr herr bringen
[Musik]
wir laufen war der kanzlerin vorbei und
schon hört auf mit regnen so muss das
sein
paragon ag im bürohaus des bundestages
zufallsbegegnung mit der parlaments
ärztin impfen ist jetzt nicht länger nur
eine private sache sondern wichtiges
politisches ziel müller ist noch nicht
gegen cupid geimpft die ärztin reed ihn
dazu dringend
es gibt ja auch ältere abgeordnete
einige monate vorher winter 2020 in
sachsen anhalt ist das gesundheitsamt in
wittenberg sind noch weitere symptome
dazugekommen kopfschmerzen durchfall
müller hat sich freiwillig gemeldet als
helfer bei der kontakt nach verfolgung
haben sie viel wort
husten seit wann hatten sie sonst noch
mit jemandem seit 30 zwölfter kontakt
was ist eigentlich also sie waren ja bei
dem kontakt ich war nicht dabei
wochenlang hilft er damals mit im amt
auch über die weihnachtstage
er erlebt engagierte beschäftigte
aber auch die schwachstellen der
deutschen verwaltung faxen statt mailen
und flexible personalplanung corona legt
offen der staat funktioniert nicht wie
er soll
vier monate später müllers wahlkampf
beginnt digital
bürgersprechstunden bei instagram und
facebook macht er jetzt regelmäßig
präsenz zeigen beim wähler auch in der
pandemie
in krawatte kommt ab die ersten schon
einige nutzen die gelegenheit corona
frust abzuladen andere wollen konkrete
antworten
warum bekomme ich keinen impftermin ob
online oder am telefon immer das gleiche
keine termine vorhanden bin in kategorie
3 seit dezember wird die luft nun merkt
man nichts von also das stimmt jetzt
nicht ganz
müller verteidigt das regierungshandeln
aber er hat auch die erfahrung aus dem
gesundheitsamt im kopf den eindruck das
land ist nicht mehr zukunftsfest
neben dem gesundheitsamt hatte ich mich
auch zur hilfe im testzentrum angeboten
und ein eine mitarbeiterin format mir
macht das ehrenamtlich und das
testzentrum konnte noch nicht starten
weil noch die behördliche abnahme das
war vorher ein sozialkaufhaus fehlte
weil dort ein feuer oder jörg gefehlt
hat
und das sind solche dinge wo ich sage
sind in der größten krise nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg uns fliegt ja fast
alles auseinander sozial kulturell
wirtschaftlich
und es hapert an dem testzentrum weil
der feuer- oder so fällt das fest wird
sich ein kopf wenn sie das wird
nicht das würde doch mal die fische
schon allerdings ist noch nicht wieder
alles andere wichtiger
ich wünsche es mir dass es angegangen
wird und ich wünsche mir auch den mut
von uns parlamentariern
die sich alle vier jahre neue plätze
suchen da sie den widerstandskräfte der
beamten auf der anderen seite auch diese
die zurückhalten können weil am ende
werden wir dafür gewählt das zu
modernisieren ein anderes gibt es nicht
mehr
[Musik]
kein bürger auch zu
spd mann detlef müller ist verabredet
mit einem barbesitzer im zwangs
geschlossenen lokal
[Musik]
oder wenn ich schon europäischen krisen
corona zwingt die branche in den
stillstand
seit monaten keine einnahmen keine
öffnungs perspektive
die wut wächst und die enttäuschung ganz
generell
kann es seinen fortschrittlichen land
das wir nie tagesaktuelle zahlen
bekommen das geht einfach nicht
dann kommt gesundheitsamt wir haben ja
noch vor zwei wochen und wir kommen noch
porto ließ verdanken dass wenn ich das
meinen jungs aus rumänien erzählen die
gucken mich an wie bitte das
funktioniert einfach geht das ist ein
viel zu bürokratisch aufgebaut also wenn
du hast viel entscheidungsebenen die
alle damit reden wollen
konsequenzen musst du auch ziehen indem
die organisation ganz anders ist also
noch viel schneller bist nicht
zuständigkeiten von oben nach unten ab
gibt's aber irgendwann muss nochmal in
behandlung
müllers parteifreund finanzminister
scholz hat schnelle hilfen versprochen
aber die auszahlung läuft quälend
langsam müller kann den pfosten
aufnehmen
und er kann ihn gut verstehen
ich sage ja modi november oder dezember
hilfen haben wir ja auch verkauft und
regierung als schnelle und
unbürokratische hilfe in der wird ganz
schnell geholfen und jeder weiß ja was
in den november haben wir helfen dann
gezahlt worden sind ende januar anfang
februar das muss man anders machen das
muss man eine kommunikation sozusagen
viel ehrlicher mit den leuten draußen
gehen und gerade bei den
überbrückungshilfen denn ich weiß dass
das noch in brüssel genehmigt werden
muss kann man davon ausgehen das es
nicht schnell gehen kann das eine ganz
logische das kann ich eigentlich sorgen
auch sie hat einen weit verbreiteten
namen nicht müller das ist im moment
alles ganz schön ausgestorben weil alle
im home office sind sondern mohammed ali
ja ja das geht
nach wie vor ich meiner klar ich bin
hier die mitarbeiter sind im home office
und weitestgehend aber das geht
eigentlich gut ich meine mit den
heutigen möglichkeiten so oder das
internet ist hier auch ziemlich stabil
dafür ganz ganz ordentlich amira
mohammed ali hat in vier jahren einen
rasanten aufstieg erlebt
2017 zog die rechtsanwältin aus
niedersachsen ins parlament ein für die
linke
[Musik]
und musste sich erst mal zurechtfinden
im labyrinth bundestag
und dann einfach
dann könnte
die fischer seien
[Musik]
mohammed ali kommt damals in eine
linksfraktion die tief verstritten ist
realo flügel gegen radikale auf wessen
seite stehst du ist die erste frage an
alle die dazu kommen ich bin jetzt hier
die neue oder einer der neun und ich
möchte mich eigentlich aus also auch das
davon abstand nehmen da jetzt eine eine
seite zu wählen und so versucht
womöglich da da sag mal konflikte weiter
weiter anzufachen also ich finde es
wichtig dass wir als linke zusammen
stehen
doch der machtkampf eskaliert
fraktionschefin wagenknecht geht auf
abstand zur eigenen partei
2009/10 wirft sehen überraschend wird
mohammed ali ihre nachfolgerin
erst seit zwei jahren im bundestag und
schon
fraktionsvorsitzende eine blitzkarriere
ihren wahlkreis hat nur mit ali in
oldenburg
[Musik]
das hatten wir kurz kurz letztes jahr
kurz vor corona gekauft
der kreisverband hat um hilfe gebeten
vor der kommunalwahl
mohammed ali quetsch das in ihrem
terminkalender als fraktionschefin
bleibt wenig zeit für direkten
bürgerkontakt
letztes mal war ich halt wirklich jedes
wochenende hier oder in der innenstadt
am stand und das kann ich diesmal nicht
weil ich halt auch bundesweit und auch
niedersachsen weiter unterwegs bin aber
es ist macht halt immer total spaß am
eigenen kreisverband und dann mache ich
das gerne wenn das geht hallo
hallo was für die
[Gelächter]
vorbehalte abbauen gegen ihre linke das
ist das ziel weg vom image der gegen
alles partei und vor allem weg von der
beschäftigung nur mit sich selbst
dass die immer weiter vorangeschritten
ist auch in der korona zeit und dass wir
jetzt wirklich endlich eine veränderung
braucht und im gesundheitswesen endlich
eine entprivatisierung dass das endlich
thema wird gute gesundheitsversorgung
für alle den unterschiede in den löwen
dass das thema wird und auch wer zahlt
am ende für die krise wir brauchen die
linke
wir brauchen aber keine linksradikal da
bin ich auch wir brauchen die rechte
genauso wie die konservativen sagen
meine kritiker ein jahr her seit die
mittel
wieder chemnitz
noch ein müller
werden mit geben hier fdp als
botschafter für chemnitz möchte mich in
berlin bewerben nein als botschaft auch
der unternehmer frank müller rosentritt
wirbt für seine wiederwahl
auch er kam 2017 für die fdp in den
bundestag damals für ihn überraschend
jetzt rechnet er mit dem erfolg
in berlin
wir erleben eine unglaublichen zuspruch
in diesem jahr einfach aufgrund
katastrophaler
regierungspolitik suche und menschen
natürlich auch nach optionen anteil
haben natürlich alle diejenigen die
heute nicht mehr an der regierung
beteiligt sind vorteile die korona
politik hat müller rosentritt in den
vergangenen monaten frustriert die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung bestimmten über alle
maßnahmen die größten grundrechts
einschränkungen seit 1945 der bundestag
schaute zu nickt er ab müller rosentritt
fürchtet bleibenden schaden an der
demokratie
entsprechen dieses handeln beobachten
diskutieren auch in einer pandemie muss
die verfassung gewahrt sein das machen
wir fast jeden tag im
gesundheitsausschuss
ein treffen mit parteifreund mit
der fdp mann vermisst offenen
meinungsstreit in der gesellschaft
das land kommt ihm verängstigt vor
gelähmt
die leidenschaftslosen kite unseres
parlamentes quasi alles
freimütig abzugeben an die exekutive
das ist die selbstaufgabe des
parlamentarismus
was ihn und seine parteifreunde am
meisten stört die pandemie hat bei
vielen sehnsucht geweckt nach einem
starken start müller rosentritt sieht
die freiheit in gefahr
wir leben in zeiten in dem der
stadt ist also die staatsgläubigkeit
extrem zunimmt wir leben in zeiten in
dem damm moralismus extrem zunimmt wenn
man sagt dass nur wenn du so denkst bist
du quasi ein richtiger mensch ich glaube
jetzt ist die zeit eben zu sagen nee ich
bin augen gut und wendig anderes denke
und ich bin ja automatisch schlecht weil
ich in die staatsgläubigen ich glaube
wir müssen stark sein wir müssen laut
sein und sagen wir als fdp sind
diejenigen die die bürgerrechte die
menschen durch die grundrechte die uns
unsere verfassung gibt verteidigen
straßenwahlkampf zwei monate vor der
wahl
für die fdp noch ein verfahren mit geben
von mir
müller rosentritt spürt viele bürger
sind erschöpft
manche hadern mit der demokratie an sich
dann widerspricht der fdp mann trotz
aller kritik an der regierung
[Musik]
wir stimmen ja demokratisch ab der
bundestag ist genauso zusammengesetzt
wie die menschen es gewählt haben und er
hat halt eben die afd nur 12 prozent
das ist halt eben 880 haben halt eine
andere auffassung dann haben kinder mehr
halten ja wir leben das er ständig
weiter in einem demokratischen staat
nein wir sind lichtjahre entfernt von
einer diktatur jeder der das behauptet
ist nicht von dieser welt trotzdem ist
es so dass wir halt eben schauen müssen
das eben bestimmte
berechtigungen die wir heute aktuell
haben die die ausschließlich die
regierung hat abgeschafft gehören
wirklich als parlament wird er über die
dinge diskutieren können und dann halt
mehrheitlich abstimmen können
o
wir laufen direkt in die arme von
hansjörg müller erwartet ärger mit der
polizei ohne maske unterwegs im münchner
hauptbahnhof
obwohl die hier pflicht ist
das ein wunder keine ahnung warum
die sogenannten querdenker haben müller
nach münchen eingeladen er soll auf
einer ihrer kundgebungen sprechen das
macht er inzwischen öfter
der höhepunkt für ihn november 2020
direkt neben dem bundestagsgebäude
demonstrieren tausende gegen die korona
gesetze
[Musik]
auch rechtsextreme vereinnahmen die wut
hans gerd müller nutzt die bühne
noch heute sollen durch die zementierung
des
ausnahmezustandes durch das neue gesetz
sollen alle mario netz auf linie
gebracht werden damit hier ist überhaupt
keine echten demokratischen
entscheidungen in diesem land mehr geben
kann das ist ein verrat an der
demokratie das ist ein verrat an der
freiheit nach hinten und überprüfen
lassen hier
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt wahrgenommen zurück in münchen
müller hat den ort der kundgebung
erreicht
nichts los gar nicht an diesem mittag
kommt kaum jemand so quer den verdienen
[Musik]
können gerne mein herz schmerz weiter ab
film hier also martin luther king
mahatma gandhi man die haben die massen
mobilisiert aber da waren die massen
auch daran interessiert mobilisiert zu
werden
blieb mit liebe deine taten du lebst
durch liebe
lebenslang wir es immer noch nicht
verstanden hat wer in tiefschlaf in der
demokratie lieber grillen geht heute als
ich hier für ihre rettung zu engagieren
der hat auch nicht anders verdient als
das in der diktatur aufwacht es ist
leider so
also wenn wir hier sage ich mal nicht
diese hedonistische wohlstands
bevölkerung hätten sondern auch schon
mal die kernigen deutschen gewisse 1989
in der ddr hatten die einfach sagen
jetzt reicht wir müssen für die freiheit
auf die straße gehen die regierung
unterdrückt uns in einem maße das ist
nicht mehr hinnehmbar wo sind hier die
menschen ja also sie hören da eine tiefe
enttäuschung
heraus
na gut dann haben wir halt nicht anders
verdient dagegen halten
eine pferderennbahn in leipzig hier muss
detlef müller zittern vor seiner spd
listenaufstellung für die bundestagswahl
die meisten müssen irgendwann dadurch
bei jeder partei
wer kommt auf die aussichtsreichen
plätze und wer nur unter ferner liefen
die aufgeregte jetzt auf einer skala
zwischen den zähnen auf neuen ja sehr
aufgeregt
naja ist ja so wird sagen würde eine
prüfung weiter das ist ja wie auf
stelzen delegierten und macht so die
bilanz der letzten jahre erklärt wo wir
noch mal antreten will und die frau ist
inhalt das für die delegierten reicht
oder nicht natürlich haben auch die
jungen delegierten er ein problem mit
mir mit meinen 57 jahren und das ist
eben so wird das ist aber normal das
ging
vor 16 jahren war detlef müller der
junge neue der kämpfen musste um seinen
platz im parlament
es ist natürlich schwierig weiß mdb ihre
themen zu besetzen in sich gegen die
alten platzhirsche durchzusetzen was für
dich schlau ist aber ich denke das geht
jeden und jeder hat mal angefangen und
dort ihr dadurch seine chance etwas zu
erreichen und guten inhalten mit guten
themen denke ich habe noch eine chance
heute drängen auffallend viele junge für
die spd in den bundestag
wir brauchen endlich überall in
deutschland gleiche lebensverhältnisse
für alle menschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
müller tritt an für listenplatz 3
auf die rede hat er sich wochenlang
vorbereitet
ich bin am 20 august 1964 in karl marx
stadt geboren als politikerinnen und
politiker ist es unsere ureigene aufgabe
ernst zu nehmen zuzuhören zu reden auch
wenn das oft sinnlos erscheint und auch
wenn das selbst und uns umstritten ist
wir sind gelassen beide arbeiten mächtig
für eine gesellschaft des respekts und
deswegen bitte ich euch um eure
unterstützung vielen dank
ich denke 50 jahre stimmen werden wir
haben
müller spürt die jungen in der partei
ticken anders für sie ist er jetzt der
platzhirsch
der alte weiße mann wie er sich selber
nennt
nur halb im scherz
listenplatz 3 detlef müller
79 abgegebene stimmzettel ein ungültiger
stimmzettel für die zeit 47 jahr stimmen
23 nein-stimmen 8 enthaltungen
60 komma irgendwas detlef ist auch
gewählt
dankeschön fürs vertrauen
das ergebnis ist noch schlechter als
gedacht
ein drittel der delegierten will ihn
nicht
das ergebnis ist wie es ist beschissen
aber es ist halt ein ergebnis
ich war dann richtig was trinken kann
man ja mal zu geben weil das stück weit
frust dabei muss das auch mal vielleicht
wegspülen so eine geschichte die rede
oder auch die letzten wochen und damit
den kopf passt weil sich darüber klar
kriegt ist es auch mal richtig heute
abend abzuschalten um das wegzuwischen
trotz der parteiinternen klatsche
listenplatz drei könnte reichen für den
bundestag es kommt jetzt auf die wälder
an
ich freue mich dass ihr den weg zum
frühschoppen gefunden haben und darf sie
herzlich begrüßen sepp müller von der
cdu ist inzwischen auf wahlkampftour
ich bewerbe mich um die verlängerung
einer befristung wichtig ist dass wir
miteinander ins gespräch kommen solche
austausche wie heute nutzen und damit
das auch einfacher klappt haben wir uns
dazu entschlossen dass wir zwei fässer
freibier sponsor poster
hallo in den gesprächen geht es nicht um
hauptstadt politik sondern um konkrete
sorgen
[Musik]
dies ist bei ihnen im grünlichen mit
masken und so weiter hat man sich dran
gewöhnen oder gibts
ja was können wir da machen als politik
keine politik mehr
attraktiver machen gemacht wird eh nicht
dass wir erklären wollen natur das
machen klein ist hat jetzt eine neue
turnhalle nach siebeneinhalb jahren ja
ja ja
zu viel bürokratie beklagen viele aber
auch klimaschutz ist zunehmend thema
nicht grundsätzlich sondern ganz konkret
das stimmt was mir auffällt ist das ganz
ganz viele und wir sind wirklich
betroffenen in der region hier wissen
dass es den klimawandel gibt also das
thema diskussion gibt es klimawandel
oder nicht nicht sondern wie
beschäftigen sich damit wie trikots
umgesetzt und da können sie im
denkmalschutz gebiet zum beispiel keine
solaranlage aufs dach bauen weil man das
nicht in der sichtachse haben darf
obwohl diejenigen gerne eine solaranlage
hätten um erneuerbare energien zu
erzeugen das sind so praktische
beispiele die melden hier die menschen
ran tragen und da geht es nicht um das
kowal galaktische sondern vor ort wo man
lösen kann
die umfragewerte der cdu sind zu dieser
zeit im sinkflug am ende könnte es
hinauslaufen auf eine koalition mit
beteiligung der grünen und klimarettung
zum knackpunkt werden
hallo hallo ich habe
heute eine heute ein aber ich habe
gedacht die schwarzen brauchen keine
grünen grün zu sein ja das kann sein
wenn wir richtig werden nicht
sechs wochen vor der wahl die grüne
wahlkampf tour macht station in
reutlingen
beate müller gemmeke hat sich einen
auftritt gesichert mit ihrem parteichef
robert habeck
[Musik]
bestimmt noch ganz wunderschöne auch
momente und aufregende momente aber das
ist schon
auch müller gemmeke ärgern die
negativschlagzeilen über die
kanzlerkandidaten berbalk wegen deren
fehler im lebenslauf und bot ihr traum
vom grünen kanzleramt ist in gefahr
da war immer noch das klima das
comeback spricht viel von freiheit und
verteidigt zugleich stärkeren
klimaschutz von grüner kanzlerschaft
kein wort
was wir schützen wenn wir das klima
schützen ist unser leben unser
verdammtes liebe und dass wenn wir
freiheit der sommer hat sich gelohnt
wenn wir ein richtig gutes wahlergebnis
haben dass wir so stark sind dass wir
reagieren können klar und am schönsten
wäre es wenn wir erste kraft werden
[Musik]
hansjörg müller von der af de gibt auf
das schade irgendwie unbeschriebenes
blatt direkt zu werfen nach vier jahren
im bundestag ist er frustriert vom
parlamentsbetrieb und seiner eigenen
partei
es ist genau so gegangen wie allen
anderen parteien vorher auch also sie
wird ferngesteuert von externen
lobbyisten die hier also ihre eigenen
sage ich mal schauspieler rumlaufen
haben bei uns in der partei ich heiße
hansjörg müller in 53 verheiratet drei
erwachsene kinder und ein süßes
enkelkind anlass des frosts bayerns afd
hat müller auf einen hinteren
listenplatz gewählt seine erzählungen
über corona waren auch den
parteifreunden suspekt die wollen das
selbstbestimmte mensch sein wie wir es
gewohnt sind abschaffen und es wird
damit enden dass wir menschen mit
maschinen zu syberbergs verschmolzen
werden
[Musik]
ja mein fehler ist die ganze zeit
gewesen ich habe mich mehreren
möglichkeiten und verlockungen mich
anzupassen denen bin ich nicht gefolgt
also mein permanenter fehler war die
ganze zeit
dass ich eben mir eigene gedanken
gemacht habe
müller könnte noch kämpfen für ein
direktmandat
aber er will zurück in seinen alten
beruf als unternehmensberater
lukrative aufträge habe er schon
[Musik]
noch einmal in chemnitz detlef müller
ist jetzt im wahlkampfmodus mit dem
spitzbübischen foto und direkt vor
wohnungstüren
guten tag faschings mit geben zumindest
kann ich dazu bilder sollten es mit
geben für die wahlen im grundgesetz dazu
dass ich so weit kann ich mal gelesen
dank twitter dass bundestagswahl angeles
begeben
ok danke schön
keinerlei aggression keine beschimpfung
bis jetzt gehabt das war 2017 ganz
anders bundesrat ist dass nicht alle mit
wähnten spd fragen kommen wären alle spd
gar nicht aber interesse
bei aller fröhlichkeit der
generationenkonflikt bleibt
lasst uns gerne direkt einsteigen
können wir wenigstens kein problem ist
perdu reden geht das viel einfacher
[Musik]
ist zur diskussion geladen bei
klimaaktivisten die verlangen harte
schnitte
energiepreise drastisch auf straßenbau
sofort stoppen junge ungeduld
müller ist das zu lebensfremd demokratie
für ihn bedeutet dass dauer suchen nach
dem kompromiss
[Musik]
müssen leute mitnehmen das konto dann
funktionieren wenn die leute das
akzeptieren und buch zu handeln und
werner familie nicht verbieten kann die
wohnung zu heizen das geht also das
wischen menschenrechte eine warme
wohnung ja aber das muss bezahlbar sein
und wo müssen dann müssen den weg finden
und das ein großes thema
steht immer von neuen problemen von den
bergen und wenn man ein thema irgendwie
man arbeitet ist einmal geschafft wurde
und auf einem guten weg ist dann kommen
wir für das nächste und
wirtschaftspolitik einlässt muss da auch
durch also es wird niemand gezwungen
deutschland im sommer 2021 ein land
erschöpft von 15 monaten im pandemie
modus gräben sind tiefer geworden
probleme liegen offener denn je manche
haben sich abgewandt von der politik
andere wollen erst recht zu packen und
mittendrin die müllers
was wir hier tun ja
spannend aufregend aber auch ganz schön
belastend aber was hilft das einzige was
hilft es reden und versuchen was zu
erklären es ist aber auch so insofern
das ist ein teil gibt dann erreichbar
ist das sind welche ich werde immer
irgendwie abgebogen ja und zum teil auch
leute die ich kenne und da werden wir
genau gucken müssen was was was hat
corona mit den menschen gemacht auf der
anderen seite es gibt ja auch immer die
andererseits es gibt ja auch zuspruch
und bestätigung und und dass das
menschen sagen dass sie das gut finden
und das waren doch weitermachen soll
wenn man politisch aktiv ist dann ist
das ja großartig wenn man so eine
gelegenheit bekommt den deutschen
bundestag sein zu können und klar dass
klar das wollte ich gerne weitermachen
nicht jetzt wieder in den bereich der
nicht wähler zurück wo ich hergekommen
bin
weil ich halte dieses system für
unehrlich ich halte für verlogen ich
halte es für betrug am bürger ich alles
für betrug an der demokratie und damit
möchte ich nichts mehr zu tun haben
unsere generation wir sind diejenigen
die das land gestalten wir sind
diejenigen die unser land nach vorne
bringen und dann kann man entweder
gestaltet werden oder selbst anspruch
haben das land selbst mitzugestalten was
wäre denn wenn es nicht klappt und dann
gehe ich wieder und die bank zurück oder
bei der lkw-fahrer ich habe
lkw-führerschein meinem vater hatten von
unternehmen und ich kann morgen auf der
lkw steigen müssen ich habe letzte woche
so viele unternehmen besucht unter
anderem für unternehmen die suche alle
lkw fahrern dann gehe ich wieder zurück
und sich entweder an die banco
laufenburg
[Musik]